Thanks for coming,
everybody.
I'm sure you all heard
there was yet another
school shooting today.
We have to figure out what
we're going to do as parents
because this whole thing
is out of control.
[ Sighs ]
We have to ask ourselves
why this is happening
and do something now!
Well, you know, Sharon,
I think it is
a complex issue, you know.
It's -- It's not really
as simple as just --
What I'm saying is that --
that with issues like this,
sometimes you have
to be kind of...crazy?
What are you
talking about?!
Do you understand that our
children are being murdered?
Red.
How much closer to home
can this all hit?
It was at our
children's school!
Crazy time.
Crazy red time.
I agree with my wife.
Well, there certainly are
things that need changing.
Just yesterday, I was
at the park with my son Craig,
and have you seen the state
of the playground equipment?
Not only does it seem unsafe,
but it's become quite
an eyesore.
The whole park could use
an upgrade, if you ask me.
It's become a camp-out
for the homeless.
Are you [bleep] joking?!
You're gonna take one second
to compare child murder
to park upgrades?!
What is wrong
with everybody?!
You've all gone crazy!
Anybody need a drink?